what up guys welcome to the just curly
things youtube channel
today i'm going to talk about um just a
thought i had about some of the
questions they asked on the kevin
samuels show fresh and fit podcast
etc um before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel
ring that notification bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos
okay so they always ask women
what they want on this channel on you
know the different man of sphere channel
so they'll say like do you want to work
to pay significant
bills um after you're pregnant
okay do you want someone taller than you
do you want you know just
they ask women all these questions and
here's the thing obviously
if you ask a girl does she want to date
a rich guy yeah what girl doesn't want a
date of rich guy
duh um or if you ask a girl do you want
to date a tall guy
she's gonna say yeah i'll give you an
example right i'm six foot
so ideally would i want to date someone
taller than me
yeah but you know if there was a guy
that had every single other quality that
i was looking for
and just happened to be a little bit
shorter than me is that gonna stop me
no and it's the same thing with men you
don't think men
want um a supermodel like if they could
have one
or whatever requirement they have you
know maybe it's values maybe because
i'm sure there's more than just looks
that guys look for but you guys get what
i'm saying
so a lot of times they'll ask these
women like what they want and the women
will tell them
but i'm sure those girls have dated guys
that did not have every single quality
that they looked for
um i do also understand their point like
the man of spheres point that women are
too picky
you know fair enough that's probably
true
i would say but i i would argue that
men are also somewhat picky about who
they get into relationships with
not who they slur or no no i take it
back men are picky about who they marry
right they're not picky about who they
date all the time they're not picky
about
who they sleep with all the time they're
picky about who they marry
and i know the men always will say well
women
um at least they're still getting sex
whatever but women don't want sex
they want relationships they want to get
married men want sex so
i don't know there's pros and cons for
both genders i didn't really have a
point it was just a thought i had today
because some of the women i see on the
on different channels
even the more reasonable ones they'll
like press them
all the time about would they prefer
someone that makes more money
and clearly the answer is yeah every
girl would prefer it but
it's not everything so i don't know my
two cents let me know in the comments
what you guys think
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
bring that notification bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos